la semaine dernière cet épicier a été
cambriolée pendant la nuit ils n'avaient
pas de protection particulière
les voleurs ont forcé la porte d'entrée
les le tiroir caisse et couper tous les
fils de la caisse ce qui a tout cassé
et puis ils ont volé tout le rayon frais
notamment les meules de comté toutes ces
choses là là ils ont tout volé et puis
derrière moi tout ce qui est conserve
également a été dérobé les cambrioleurs
ont emporté 1000 euros de caisse et 3000
euros de marchandise le gérons va
désormais installé une alarme car cette
épreuve là évidemment marqué le matin ça
fait bizarre quand on rentre dans le
magasin c'est ouf on a toujours peur que
ça accès recommencer mais après on
reprend le dessus surtout dans la
situation actuelle est ce qu'on veut
c'est rouvrir pour offrir au village la
possibilité d'avoir des produits frais
les commerçants ne sont pas les seules
victimes de cambriolages
les entreprises sont aussi visés ici par
exemple deux week-ends de suite des
personnes cagoulées ont découpé le
grillage et visité plusieurs semi
remorque mais au final rien n'a été
dérobé
le directeur que nous avons pu joindre à
distance se montre désormais
particulièrement vigilant du bâtiment
également
d'autres entreprises du secteur ont
décidé de doubler leur nombre de rondes
pour éviter tout préjudice